il dono nella nostra cultura di donne e
uomini dell'occidente richiede una
giustificazione non è per così dire un
atto con se tu dinario un atto della
vita quotidiana è un atto che richiede
degli eventi particolari noi abbiamo
creato le occasioni per donarci e
scambiarci doni compleanni nel sud
europa gli onomastici alcuni eventi
particolari le cresime e comunioni le
ricorrenze dei matrimoni le nozze d'oro
le nozze d'argento
il natale è questo grande evento che è
già quasi preannunciato dalle luminarie
nelle nostre città che l'occidente ha
inventato mettendo insieme ai laici
religiosi e anche religioni diverse per
appunto consolidare insieme questo
grande evento che il dono
perché nella cultura occidentale
noi non abbiamo diciamo questa
naturalità predisposizione al dono
perché noi siamo una cultura e non è una
sottolineatura etica nella
sottolineatura antropologica culturale
che quella del possesso delle cose
dell'acquisto delle cose dello scambio
delle cose non abbiamo il marchio del
dono perché nella cultura occidentale e
quello che prevale che ha sempre
prevalso e la cultura del io gli uni o
forte di un mio completo di un io che si
autodefinisce nella sua autonomia
pensate alla vostra terra pensate a
questa città che ha visto fin dal
settecento fiorire figure di
imprenditori saldissimi che hanno creato
ricchezza lavoro appunto all'interno di
un interpretazione della vita attraverso
un mio forte autonomo come quello
dell'imprenditorialità ci sono altre
culture per cui si può dividere il mondo
in una sorta di dicotomia geografica
da una parte l'occidente un po
ossessionato dal tema del guadagno da
tema del danaro
fin qui il cus timi anni pensate a wall
street in questi ultimi anni esasperato
una visione finanziaria della vita e
dall'altra un secondo un terzo mondo non
so più quanti siano dove li è un po più
debole pensate alle culture dell'india
pensate alle culture zen pensate alle
culture di certi paesi del sudamerica
dove prevale di più la solidarietà
lo scambio appunto la cultura del dono
ripeto non voglio dare nessuna
connotazione etica a questi due
dicotomie a questi due mondi sono i due
dati culturali un grande sociologo del
secolo scorso max weber diceva che in
fondo c'è un rapporto diretto tra lo
sviluppo dell'imprenditorialità e
l'etica protestantesimo
ci sono delle eccezioni io vengo dal
veneto sono cresciuto sul nato sul lago
di garda e sono cresciuto a verona il
nord est è stato contrassegnato in
questi ultimi anni
nell'immaginario collettivo del nostro
paese come il posto dei soldi gente
assatanata intorno ai sky
eppure ed è degno della massima nota nel
veneto ci sono le punte più alte di
volontariato c'è un volontariato diffuso
soprattutto nelle giovani generazioni
ora come si spiega tutto questo si
spiega
o meglio si spiega ci si può riflettere
sopra pensando che per certi aspetti il
dono sotto forma di servizio e come se
scomparisse resta il servizio e il
servizio spesso non è visto come un dono
mai visto come una svolta come dire
volontaristica di tipo individuale dove
il collettivo diventa un fatto
abbastanza momentaneo e non stabile il
volontariato il dono offerto solo come
forma di servizio
talvolta rende il dono un gesto
inconsapevole i miei amici volontari
dell'est del nord est del nostro paese
non sanno in fondo di donarsi lo fanno
lo fanno con una naturalità simile a
quella che poi di giorno li porta a
lavorare tantissimo intorno all impresa
intorno al lavoro in tono all'accumulo
della ricchezza individuale cosentono
secondo un sociologo americano dono è
ogni prestazione di beni o servizi
effettuata senza garanzia di
restituzione
questo è il dato centrale si dona senza
aspettare di essere risarciti al fine di
creare alimentare o ricreare il legame
sociale tra le persone quindi c'è un
tratto del tutto oblativo nei confronti
dell'altro si crea l'altro si crea
legame
con l'altro attraverso la donazione del
sé o di oggetti o di servizi non c'è
nessuna attesa di restituzione di
scambio su questa base
volevo introdurre la seconda parte della
mia riflessione introduce un concetto di
ambiguità rispetto al donare e non do ad
ambiguità nessuna connotazione etica
l'ambiguità è una speciale one
psicologica che contiene aspetti diversi
di una realtà molteplici trattenendo i
quali noi possiamo di tale realtà
cogliere aspetti che tendenzialmente non
riusciamo a cogliere anche perché
scomodi
anche perché perturbanti c'è
un'ambiguità di primo ordine che
sperimentiamo spesso anche nel nostro
paese attraverso i media
padre alex zanotelli missionario
comboniano di grande valore un grande
uomo
recentemente ha detto i poveri in realtà
non hanno bisogno della nostra carità ma
solo di modifiche strutturali
eppure noi doniamo doniamo attraverso i
telefonini 2 euro 5 euro
partecipiamo alle galoppate televisive
perché facciamo questo probabilmente
dice padre alex zanotelli per pulirsi la
coscienza nel caldo nelle stanze comode
delle nostre case
noi con un gesto anche generoso anche
altruistico doniamo e in questo sentiamo
tranquilli nel partecipare a una
missione collettiva della quale non
siamo artefici ma della quale siamo
seguaci e che in fondo se noi
riflettiamo bene non risolve il problema
dei donati che hanno bisogno che
avrebbero bisogno di ben altro eppure
tutto questo avviene in maniera
abbastanza diffusa e continua il tutto
l'occidente e di fronte anche ai 20
drammatici sono stati ricordati i
terremoti di tahiti noi
doniamo
poche lire pochi euro e con questo per
certi aspetti laviamo le nostre
coscienze
gli occidentali rispetto a questo altro
mondo misterioso nel quale succedono a
catastrofi e nei confronti delle quali
siamo solo capaci dice padre zanotelli
di intervenire da lontano senza
preoccuparci delle ragioni profonde che
generano quei bisogni così drammatici in
quelle popolazioni così sofferenti ma
c'è un'ambiguità di secondo ordine che
forse anche più speciosa forse anche più
perturbante sulla quale riflettere
insieme stamane noi come rappresentanti
di sapiens donne e uomini
nasciamo mancanti è un dato biologico
non è né un bene in sé un mare la natura
è la natura non è classificabile in
termini di difetti o di superiorità le
donne e gli uomini per una serie di
situazioni legate alla speciazione umana
all'evoluzione che ci ha portato a
sapiens nascono con un tratto di
mancanza biologica cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che il cucciolo della donna e
dell'uomo
a differenza dei cuccioli degli animali
superiori a cui noi partecipiamo cioè i
mammiferi non riescono a sopravvivere da
soli i nostri cuccioli hanno bisogno di
qualcuno che li prenda una madre
mediamente brava o chi sostituisce
questa madre e li porta al seno e in
questo sopravvivono in questo gesto
fondamentale che spesso è dimenticato
c'è uno stato di mancanza che ci
accompagna per tutta la vita e che si
sviluppa un sentimento di carenza questo
sentimento di carenza non può essere
risolto dall'accaparramento o dal
possesso di beni può essere risolto solo
dalla relazione con l'altro che rimanda
a quella antica relazione con la madre
dalla quale noi abbiamo tratto la nostra
origine e attraverso la quale noi siamo
sopravvissuti
la relazione con l'altro diventa dono
diventa scambio e uno scambio
altruistico nulla è più al turistico del
gesto della madre che porge un seno a
una piccola bocca affamata nel dono c'è
il riconoscimento dell'altro e
attraverso il riconoscimento si fonda
l'identità che poi sostanzialmente
accompagna lo stato di mancanza in una
svolta però evolutiva noi attraverso
questo cerchio che è un cerchio virtuoso
e non vizioso
siamo diventati quello che siamo siamo
qui in questo posto così sofisticato
come un teatro in una città così bella
come como di fronte a un evento come ted
che un evento alto di cultura collettiva
adulta
tutto questo nasconde tuttavia un dato
di ambiguità intendo e ripeto in
qualcosa che ci porti ad approfondire la
situazione relazionale
guardate queste due parole hostess e
hospice sono due parole della lingua
latina che hanno il significato opposto
lontano dapprima nemico la seconda
ospite hanno la stessa radice os che
deriva dalla radice indoeuropea che
significa off che significa chiedo scusa
che significa casolare casa calore nella
lingua tedesca contemporanea off
e tutto ciò che indica albergo locanda
dove ti danno qualcosa di buono ti danno
un eletto del mangiare ospitalità ma la
casa rivela contemporaneamente il nemico
è l'ospite nella casa c'è anche
l'insidia l'ospite che arriva e
intrusivo è qualcosa che ci trafigge
dopo un po di tempo che si metta il
nostro posto che dice qualcosa di
l'inusitato rispetto a quello che noi
siamo abituati a sentire della nostra
casa e di noi stessi e perturbante il
dono arriva inatteso nella sua
specificità e capace di essere intrusivo
ed interpretare aspetti della nostra
personalità che noi non conoscevamo o
che se abbiamo conosciuto abbiamo
riposto in luoghi nascosti della nostra
anima perché sono disturbanti e il dono
può scavare può mettere in luce questi
aspetti
e allora diventa una struttura con due
facce una faccia positiva e una faccia
che non è negativa in sé ma che è una
faccia perturbante proprio perché scopre
il perturbante che in noi perché appunto
scava interpreta ci porta a cogliere di
noi
alcuni aspetti ripeto che noi al limite
conoscevamo inconsapevolmente ma che
l'atto del dono il dono in sé
quell'oggetto o quel servizio quel gesto
hanno riportato alla luce da un passato
sepolto ma non per questo meno vibrante
e meno vero
ci sono aspetti a volte fascinosi in
tutto questo ci sono aspetti a volte
inconsueti
ci sono aspetti che perturbano che
lasciano una striscia di non detto
una striscia di imbarazzo una striscia
di inconsueta tribolazione affettiva li
andiamo a certi proverbi della nostra
cultura anche contadina nella nostra
cultura del secolo scorso
l'ospite dopo tre giorni
oddio arriva la mamma dice che non sa
quando andrà via
resta lungo con noi cosa facciamo
l'altro ieri in televisione hanno ri
proiettato un film di woody allen
bruges mi è la storia di due sorelle e
quando la sorella non sofisticata arriva
a casa la sorella sofisticata alta
borghese si preoccupa della propria vita
personale che ha sconvolta dall'arrivo
della sorella che peraltro li fa molto
piacere quando apriremo un dono a natale
e scopriremo che non sarà così vicino a
noi
ricordiamoci di questa di quest'incontro
una mattina triste ma non per questo
meno feconda
grazie